I think a watch of course is always  something that nicely complements a  man's a gentleman's outfit so of course  you need to be a bit careful with what  type of watch you're wearing first I  probably would avoid watches this cost  more than 10 000 Euro or ten thousand  dollars or very expensive watches again  in general you want to avoid creating  the impression in front of your clients  that you are extremely rich extremely  loaded and then also second certain  brands the classical one are Rolex  watches I think in general Rolex watches  are great I can understand why many  people like them but maybe if you have  one rather keep it to yourself for your  leisure time maybe with your friends if  you hang out in the evening but maybe  not during your work day if you work in  Consulting again this might just create  the wrong impression for you